Herzlich Willkommen zu Alternativlos Version 1. Warum Alternativlos?
Na, wir konnten nicht anders.
Wir konnten nicht anders, genau. Wir mussten jetzt endlich mal stehen.
Wir können nicht anders.
Zum Glück sitzen wir, es ist kühl. Wir sitzen in der Raumfahrtagentur und hartwegs ruhig ist es auch. Wenn ihr Hintergrundgeräusche hört, dann hört ihr Hintergrundgeräusche. Worüber wollen wir reden? Wir fangen mal an mit ein bisschen Finanznews, nicht wahr?
Also wir haben uns überlegt, wir machen so ein bisschen wie die Fnord News Show, aber mit Themen, die sich nicht so auf zehn Sekunden runterkondensieren lassen.
Und ohne Bilder.
Genau, bei der Fnord Show sind wir immer sehr visuell, weil das lässt sich halt besser kommunizieren, als wenn wir da groß erzählen.
Aber hier haben wir dann doch mal einfach nur Radio.
Genau, hier haben wir Zeit und müssen nicht ein ganzes Jahr erbilden. Wir haben uns ein paar Themen aufgeschrieben, die wir mal angehen wollten.
Genau, du wolltest erklären, warum Griechenland am Ende der Gewinner ist.
Nee, warum Deutschland der Gewinner ist.
Achso, genau. Und Griechenland der Verlierer.
Griechenland, ja. Ach naja, es ging ja los damit. Das heißt, Griechenland ist jetzt pleite, ist mit dem Geld unseriös umgegangen und reitet die ganze EU in die Scheiße. Das war ja die Ansage am Anfang.
Genau, so haben wir das gemacht, was alle getan haben. Nur ein bisschen mehr.
Genau. Also insbesondere von Anfang an hieß es eben, Griechenland ist schuld. Und ich habe vor einer Weile so ein Buch gelesen, das heißt Confessions of an Economic Hitman.
Der Klassiker.
Genau. Und da steht eben drin, das ist aus den 70ern das Buch. Das kann man übrigens an der Stelle gerne weiterempfehlen. Das ist von einem Mann, der für den Weltwährungsfonds gearbeitet hat und der ist in die Länder der dritten Welt geschickt worden. Also die Bezeichnung Economic Hitman, also Wirtschaftsattentäter, die kommt von ihm, um zusammenzufassen, was er tut. Der hieß natürlich eigentlich Consultant oder was man nach und sagt. Also es gab da einen ganz seriösen Namen dafür, aber seine Aufgabe war im Wesentlichen in die dritte Welt zu fahren und die Länder dazu zu bringen, dass sie Infrastruktur kaufen im Westen. Also hauptsächlich waren das irgendwie Strom und Wasser und Straßen. Ja, eher Strom, weil da muss man mehr importieren. Also die Idee war, denen möglichst was mit Gefälle zu verkaufen, was sie selber nicht bauen können. Und ihnen erst zu sagen, ihr braucht das und zweitens, na ja, wir können euch das schnell, schnell beschaffen, sodass am Ende das Geld aus der dritten Welt in die erste Welt floss.
Wurden auch das Geld, was ihnen zuerst per Kredit gebaut wurde?
Na ja, Moment, also es gibt da zwei Phasen. Es gab die erste Phase, das haben sie bei Ländern wie Saudi Arabien als Ziel gehabt. Also es gibt ja auch reiche Länder in der dritten Welt mit viel Rohstoffen. Also das Ziel von der ganzen Schose ist quasi an die Rohstoffe heranzukommen und die Länder zu versklaven und zwar sie so tief in die Schulden rein zu reißen beim Westen, dass sie da nie wieder aus eigener Kraft rauskommen können und am Ende a. abhängig sind und b. für die erste Welt abstimmen, wenn es im Sicherheitsrat oder bei der UNO-Vollversammlung irgendwelche wackeligen Sachen zu beschließen sind. Und die Methode war eben hingehen im Grunde, dem Land Infrastruktur geben oder aufschwatzen und das ist immer von Westfirmen gemacht worden. Und es gab dann natürlich irgendwann Länder, die haben sich gedacht naja, eigentlich ist das ja eigentlich unsere Infrastruktur, die wollen wir schon selber bauen. Dann haben wir versucht, das Geld, was ihnen geliehen wurde, das ist also Phase 2, dass der Weltwährungsfonds dann Kredite verteilt und haben dann versucht, dieses Geld so anzulegen, dass es der eigenen Industrie zugutekommt. Und das hat der Weltwährungsfonds nicht mit sich machen lassen.
Das heißt ja noch mal gleich Protektionismus.
Genau, das ist Protektionismus. Und der Weltwährungsfonds knüpft seine Kredite eben an Anforderungen, denen man genügen muss. Und dazu gehört eben, dass man seinen Markt öffnet. Das ist so die Hauptanforderung, dass man seinen Markt liberalisiert, so nennen die das immer. Das heißt, dass man Schutzzölle abbaut, damit der Markt sich nicht mehr wehren kann gegen die subventionierten Billigprodukte aus dem Westen.
Genau, weil subventionieren ist ja was ganz anderes als Protektionismus.
Genau, also warum wir jetzt ausholen, wenn wir uns mal die Ergebnisse angucken für die Länder der dritten Welt, dann sind die a. in tiefen Schulden, b. haben sie Infrastruktur gekauft, die sie mehr oder weniger nicht brauchen.
Dann nicht nur Infrastruktur, sondern auch Waffen.
Ja, Waffen natürlich auch. Also das Problem ist, es gab auch Länder, die haben keine Infrastruktur gebraucht. Also dieses Buch ist sehr witzig, als es um Saudi-Arabien geht, weil denen haben sie gesagt, hört mal, ihr habt hier keine Müllabfuhr. Also die waren total schockiert, als er mit seinen Kollegen den Saudi-Arabien aufschlug, weil die haben ihren Müll einfach auf die Straße gekippt und haben gesagt, das Tragen von dem Müll, das ist uns unwürdig, das machen wir nicht. Und die Müllabfuhr hat so funktioniert, dass es Ziegen gab, die dann Müll gefressen haben. Und die westlichen Berater kamen an und sehen das und haben sich gedacht, ach, meine Güte, die werden uns sofort alles abkaufen. Und die Saudis haben gesagt, na ja, funktioniert doch. Also das ist schon nicht unbedingt immer ein Selbstläufer, den Leuten sowas zu verkaufen. Aber jetzt guckt euch mal an, was die dritte Welt, quasi was wir dir angetan haben. Und dann betragt es mal auf Griechenland. Da läuft das nämlich ähnlich. Also wir haben, Griechenland hat natürlich selber Industrie und könnte selber Stromkraftwerke bauen. Aber nicht zuletzt auf Drängen von Deutschland haben wir EU-Richtlinien zum Umweltschutz und zur Effizienz von Kraftwerken und ähnlichen Sachen. Das heißt, Griechenland könnte zwar einen Kraftwerk bauen, aber das wäre nicht effizient. Das würde den EU-Richtlinien nicht genügen. Und deswegen haben wir also quasi dieselbe Masche, die wir früher mit der dritten Welt abgezogen haben. Die ziehen wir jetzt mit Ländern wie Griechenland ab. Also ich jetzt auch nicht mehr hin. Zwischen, jetzt ist die nächste Runde langsam. Aber also von dem Effekt für die einzelnen Länder ist das sehr vergleichbar. Das war irgendwann so die Erkenntnis, die mir gekommen ist.
Also gerade so der Griechenland dann so. Es ist ja auch so, dass teilweise die Forderungen ja total offen waren. Dass gesagt wurde, ja also wenn wir denen jetzt irgendwie Geld leihen oder Kredite geben oder was auch immer, dann müssen wir aber auch sicherstellen, dass das Geld wieder zurückfließt. Also dass halt dafür deutsche Produkte gekauft werden. Oder also das ist de facto halt eine deutsche Wirtschafts-Bürgschafts-Forderung.
Genau. Also das war übrigens Phase drei bei denen, beim Economic Hitman, dass sie das Geld gar nicht mehr ausgezahlt haben an die Länder.
Sondern gleich Lebensmittelgutscheine.
Genau. Die haben direkt sozusagen betreuernd Firmen eingerichtet, die das dann quasi in Naturalien, also direkt an die eigenen Firmen, Bei Waffen ist das ja völlig üblich.
Also das ist halt so, dass der, wenn du in Deutschland ein U-Boot kaufst, und jetzt nicht gerade Israel bist, dann kriegst du der geschenkt. Aber ansonsten ist es dann Christian...
Hermes-Bürgschaft.
Genau. Du kriegst einen Kredit dafür oder eine Hermes-Bürgschaft. Und dann, ja, gucken wir mal. Also die das Geld leistet bei der deutschen Industrie. Insofern zu großen Teilen. Und die, ja, ob sie denn damit was anfangen können mit den U-Booten oder was auch immer. Also Griechenland hat ja genau dieses...
Griechenland, den haben wir auch U-Boote angekündigt. Das ist ja witzig eigentlich, weil sie die natürlich überhaupt nicht gebraucht haben. Also überhaupt nicht.
Da gab es doch diese interessante Zahl, dass... Also Griechenland befindet sich ja in so einem schwelenden Dauerkonflikt mit der Türkei. Und da gab es ja diese interessante Zahl, dass Deutschland 14 und 15 Prozent der jeweiligen Rüstungsgüterankäufe ausmacht. Das heißt also die Türkei...
Die verkaufen natürlich an beide Seiten, ist ja klar. Die Amis im Kosovo-Krieg.
Naja, oder wie die DDR halt im ersten Golfkrieg. Die LKWs wurden halt an beide Seiten geliefert. Natürlich. Also genau dieses Herstellen von Abhängigkeiten und Ausnutzen von Konfliktsituationen, ist natürlich ein altes Spiel.
Das ist ein altes Spiel. Aber also die zentrale Erkenntnis für mich war jedenfalls, dass man sehen kann, Griechenland endet genauso wie die dritte Welt geendet hat damals. Nämlich sie haben hohe Schulden, wenn die auch nicht direkt bei Deutschland sind. So sind sie bei unseren Banken. Das stand in der Presse.
Was im Übrigen noch der Grund war, warum diese Bailout-Geschichte passieren musste, weil die Banken zu viel davon in den Bilanzen hatten.
Na, na, na, na. Also da gab es ja noch einen anderen Grund für den Konflikt. Der Bailout hat den Euro gesenkt und das mussten wir machen, weil wir im Außenhandel von den Amerikanern unter Druck gesetzt worden sind, die den Dollar gekostet haben.
Jetzt steigt der Euro gerade wieder ans 30 Mal wieder. Das heißt, wir werden demnächst die nächste Euro kriegen.
Wir brauchen noch einen Bailout. Aber das ist ja schon angekündigt. Es gibt ja schon die Ansage Spanien, Portugal.
Achso, ja klar, das heißt, wenn wir den entsprechenden Bailout sehen, um den wir uns groß wieder unter Kontrolle zu bringen. Also lieber noch mal schnell nach Amieland fahren und Urlaub machen.
Also die interessanteste Frage an der Stelle ist natürlich, machen die das mit Absicht? Also sind die so schlau? Ist das alles von langer Hand geplant?
Ich hab da immer gewisse Zweifel. Also wenn man den durchschnittlichen Politiker trifft, dann hat man immer Probleme sich vorzustellen. Die könnten so eine lange Verschwörung auf die Reihe kriegen. Ich meine, es gibt also ein paar Außennamen, so Schäuble oder so, wo die es vielleicht noch zutrauen.
Aber bei den meisten fragt man sich, ob die ohne Dienstwagen zur Arbeit finden würden.
Also ich meine, das stellt sich mal vor, Guido Westerwelle würde irgendjemanden eine Verschwörung unterstellen. Das wäre schon schwierig. Gut, also vielleicht gibt es ja auf der Arbeitsebene Leute, die irgendwie dazu der Lage sind, bei denen man halt irgendwie entsprechende langfristige Planung vermuten könnte. Also ich meine, diese Euro-Geschichte, da war ja auch so eine interessante Theorie, zu sagen, dass dieses ganze Konstrukt mit Geld nach Deutschland fließen lassen und den Euro so aufsetzen, dass am Ende das Geld in Deutschland landet. Ja, also das wird halt zu Kohlzeiten von den Erwachsenen, die damals das Land regiert haben.
Das war eine der Thesen, die wir gelesen haben. Ich kann das ja immer noch nicht ganz glauben, weil wir waren ja damals alt genug, wir haben das live miterlebt, das ist so ausgeschlossen.
Wahrscheinlich ist einfach der Kontrast so rückwirkend betrachtet zu dem, was wir heute so an Politikerkopfzeug haben. Also die waren ja damals schon scheiße.
Das kann natürlich sein. Also das wirkt alles so ein bisschen wie die StudiVZ-Variante von der CoE-Regierung gerade.
Was wir jetzt haben.
Aber es ist ganz lustig, wenn es so einen überhängenden Regenschirm gibt, der immer zutrifft, dann die Sachen sind uns genau gegenteilig verkauft worden. Also der Euro-Bailout war ja was furchtbar schlechtes, was wir notgedrungen machen mussten. Das war alternativlos, aber eigentlich wollten wir es nicht. Das war so die Presse-Sachen und Griechenland war ja auch furchtbar. Also als uns das hier in der Presse mitgeteilt wurde, das war ja auch alles oh mein Gott. Aber eigentlich ist es das Beste, was uns passieren konnte.
Genau.
Also hier unsere Exporte donnern jetzt wieder.
Na ja, also insofern war es vielleicht wirklich alternativlos.
Ja, schon, aber aus anderem Grund.
Aber ja, ich meine, also die interessante Frage wird ja am Ende sein, wie hier von dem Bailout wird dann tatsächlich in dem Sinne einen Anspruch genommen, dass man, also das Geld weg ist. Also sozusagen nicht nur...
Na ja, ein bisschen Verlust hast du ja immer. Aber also den Bailout, den wir Griechenland ausgezahlt haben, das ist ja, das haben ja Leute verfolgt, was mit dem Geld gemacht wurde. Und ein Gutteil davon ist direkt genutzt worden, um Kredite bei deutschen Banken zu tilgen.
Ja, also die Staatsanleitung abzukaufen.
Genau, das heißt, damit haben wir quasi unsere Banken gerettet, nicht Griechenland, unsere Banken haben wir gerettet. Und das Geld hätten wir denen auch direkt geben können, aber das wäre halt eine Verletzung der internationalen WIPO- und WTO-Verträge gewesen. Und das ist so eine wesentliche Beobachtung, die wir immer wieder machen können. Im Grunde, was geschieht, auch diese U-Boot-Geschichte mit Israel, also der Haupteffekt ist natürlich, dass man in der Presse groß schwadronieren kann von wegen Israel und U-Boote, aber eigentlich haben wir Arbeitsplätze gehalten und wir haben dafür gesorgt, dass diese U-Boot-Werften bestehen bleiben, die wohl ein einzigartiges Know-how haben. Und das ist tatsächlich ein strategisches Ziel, dass dieses Know-how in Deutschland erhalten bleibt.
Da gab es ja gerade diese lustige Geschichte, als die Bundeswehr sagte, sie würde jetzt gerne mal ein paar irgendwie von diesen verkackten Rüstungsprojekten abschaffen wollen.
Genau, da haben sich dann die ganzen Rüstungsindustrie zusammengetan.
Interessant war ja, dass die die Gewerkschaft mobilisiert haben.
Naja, aber das macht ja Sinn. Weil die CDU ist ja sowieso auf ihrer Seite, das sind ja schon immer die Rüster. Und wenn du die SPD willst, musst du die Gewerkschaft erschienen.
Also interessant ist halt, dass diese Rüstungsprojekte, von denen die reden, also wenn man sich die mal so im Detail anguckt, zum Beispiel dieser Hubschrauber, dieser NH90, das ist halt irgendwie so, also so eine Serie, also wir sind ja nun schon so verkackt im Industriemarstab gewöhnt so von T-Systems und Co.
Gut, ich meine, wir suchen das auch immer raus, muss man sagen, ja? Wir bewegen uns ja auch, diese Sachen zu sehen.
Ja, aber ich meine, selbst noch diesen...
Aber wir haben schon Sachen gesehen, aber das, ich meine, das ist auch immer wieder... Man denkt, also man hat ja so naiv das Gefühl, es geht hier um die Verteidigung des Landes, ja, da werden die schon richtige, schon richtige Firmen beauftragen und sich bemühen, dass das nicht, sagen wir, bei T-Systems landet oder so. Ja, war weit gefehlt. Das wird genauso verkackt wie alle anderen Projekte.
Ich finde es sogar noch schlimmer, wenn man sich so anguckt, wie die...
Es gibt da, also bei Deutschland habe ich jetzt gar nicht mehr so im Kopf, aber es gab diese Geschichte mit dem Helikopter aus England, das war glaube ich nicht der Eurofighter, aber es war ein Flugzeug, es gab einen Helikopter, der nicht bei Regen fliegen konnte und es gab ein Flugzeug, wo sie vorne aus Geldgründen die Bordkanone ausgebaut haben. Dann haben sie festgestellt, dass das Ding nicht mehr fliegt, weil das Gewicht nicht mehr gut verteilt war und haben vorne Blei eingebaut. Also diese Rüstungsprojekte gehen alle so tierartig der Reihe nach. Wenn man sich das von außen anguckt, kann man sich nur fragen, was ist denn, wenn das wirklich mal einer angreift?
Das sieht man ja gerade in Afghanistan. Also die ganzen Probleme, die jetzt da durch die Presse liefen, waren ja zur Hälfte halt Equipment-Probleme mit so Sachen wie, haben sie den bei irgendeinem von diesen gepanzerten Fahrzeugen, sind die Bremsleitungen außen und die Druck, also so jedenfalls so, dass sie halt getroffen werden. Und die Klimaanlage ist auch irgendwie gefährdet und noch irgendwas. Also jedenfalls so lauter verwundbare Teile sind irgendwie so außen oben so. Das heißt, irgendwie mit so ein paar gezielten Schüssen ist diese Ding Bewegungsunfähigkeit, dann kannst du nicht mehr fahren. Also das kommt ja hier. Und dann grills dich auch noch, weil die Klimaanlage kaputt ist. Also du denkst dir so, man sollte doch auch denken, so Armeen, die von...
Warum soll es denen auch besser gehen als den Bahnkunden?
Man sollte doch so denken, so Armeen haben doch irgendwie jetzt schon so eine gewisse längliche Erfahrung, so deutsche Rüstung, so das Tri-Dekadent.
Ja, ja, das ist nicht zu glauben, ich mein, also ohne jetzt irgendwie zu tief reinzugreifen, die deutsche Armee hat eigentlich langjährige Erfahrungen mit Kriegen, die verloren gehen, weil wir auf die Witterung nicht vorbereitet sind. Und insofern hätte ich eigentlich auch gedacht, aber nein, ich meine, man muss sie einfach vor Augen halten. Das gibt alles erst dann Sinn, wenn man sich davon verabschiedet, dass die Armee gebaut wird, um das Land zu schützen. Das ist einfach nicht der Grund, sondern das geht um Industrieförderung. Die Waffen werden im Inland gekauft, damit wird unsere Airbus, EADS, also die Rüstungskonzerne, die wir haben, die bauen ja alle auch andere Sachen, aber damit sind sie halt nicht konkurrenzfähig. Und damit sie das unter Preis verkaufen können, um doch konkurrenzfähig zu sein, haben die eben alle eine Rüstungssparte, über die der Staat...
Über die die Subventionen defakt...
Genau, die Subventionen da reinpumpt, ohne dass es als Subvention aufhält.
Das ist ja im Prinzip, was die Amis entwickelt haben, um den Europäern direkte Subventionen vorwerfen zu können, aber...
Wobei die Amis haben da ja auch keine Zurückhaltung.
Nee, nee, überhaupt nicht. Also, bevor wir da völlig abschleifen von den Finanzen, heute war ja diese lustige Meldung, dass der Boss von der IKB, einer von diesen Banken, die da 17 Milliarden in irgendwelchen Firmen...
Staatliche Banken...
.Firmen außerhalb der Bilanz gebunkert hatte, die sie in Schrotty-Anleihen aus Amiland, irgendwelche Immobiliengiftanleihen gebunkert haben. Und der ist wegen der falschen Darstellung des Zustands der Bank...
In der Pressemitteilung.
In der Pressemitteilung. Er hat offensichtlich den Zustand der Bank etwas rosiger dargestellt als er war. Woraufhin wutgläubige Anleger, ich weiß nicht, ob es sowas überhaupt noch gibt, die Aktie gekauft haben, was dann dazu führte, dass sie dann halt hinterher ein bisschen Nese waren. Und nun haben wir mal geguckt, er hat also zur Strafe von 100.000 Euro verurteilt worden.
Und wir haben gedacht, boah, 100.000 Euro, das ist ja kein Pappenstiel.
Und 10.000 Euro für Bewehrung, genau.
Und dann haben wir mal geguckt, was der eigentlich so einen Bonus gekriegt hat in einem Jahr.
Genau. Und 2007, 2008 hat er eine Million Bonus bekommen. Das heißt, das hat jetzt sozusagen noch eine 10% Schurkensteuer auf den Bonus gezahlt.
Genau, da haben wir mehr Umsatzsteuer als das.
Ja, genau.
Also doppelt so viel.
Das heißt, der hat jetzt gerade mal tatsächlich einen Sinn für einen Steuersatz nur auf seinen Bonus gezahlt.
So sieht das aus.
Tja, naja, in der besten Tradition der deutschen Justiz, wenn es um Banken geht.
Na ja, wir haben noch so eine andere Sache, die wir mal ansprechen wollten, aber wo es so ein bisschen schwierig ist, die anzusprechen, wie ein Paragraf 90 Strafgesetzbuch.
Was ist ein Paragraf 90 Strafgesetzbuch?
Das ist, dass man den Bundespräsidenten nicht beleidigen oder verleunten darf.
Ach genau, ja, das stimmt, der Bundespräsident hat ja...
Das ist eine lange Tradition, das gibt es ja auch in anderen Monarchien. Ach so, ja, man darf sagen, Majestätbeleidigung.
In Thailand ist es ja durchaus richtig mit Kast und Sonne.
Ich glaube auch die Briten sind da eigentlich unentspannt, wenn es darum geht.
Majestätbeleidigung ist doof. Das Problem ist halt nur doof, wenn man dann so eine Majestät hat, die halt irgendwie eigentlich eher disbeleidigend ist.
Ja gut, ich meine Hannover, da denken viele an, ja ist ja Ernst, nee, Erich, wie ist denn dieser Prügelprinz nochmal da?
Ernst August.
Ernst August, der war auch ein Hannoveraner.
Das ist so eine der ersten Sachen, die einfällt.
Aber in Hannover gibt es auch noch ein Rotlichtviertel, das einen beeindruckend großen Einfluss auf die Machtverhältnisse zu haben scheint.
Genau, und da gab es halt neulich diese Geschichte mit dem lustigen Friedensvertrag zwischen den Hells Angels und den Bandidos, die in der Anwaltskanzlei von Gerd Schröder geschlossen wurden.
Von einem Kumpel von Gerd. Und da gibt es also so einen informellen Club der Freunde von Gerd Schröder, und die heißen Friends of Gerd. Und die Kanzlei gehört da also einem von denen. Und da denkt man sich, wer geht denn in so eine Kanzlei und denkt so in Industrie-Manglanten. Aber auch Rocker-Bands gehen dahin, erstaunlicherweise.
Ja, ich meine, wenn du einen guten Anwalt brauchst und viel Geld hast, dann ist man ein guter Anwalt. Na jedenfalls sind die Sachen mit dem Bundespräsidenten insofern lustig, als sich mal wieder zeigt, wie wichtig guter Lokalsynalismus ist. Also wenn man halt irgendwie die Dinge wissen will, die lokal in Hannover passiert sind. Nur leider war es dann so, dass ein großer deutscher Presseverlag offensichtlich mehr über die Geschehnisse wusste als alle anderen und die Erkenntnisse gebunkert hat. Und dann vermutlich irgendeinen Deal gemacht hat, sie nicht zu publizieren. Jedenfalls blieb dann allen anderen Zeitungen nichts weiter übrig, als über das Tattoo der neuen Präsidentengatte zu schreiben.
Also es gibt in Hannover zwei große Zeitungen und die gehören beide demselben Verlag. Und dem gehören noch die Wurstblätter der Lokalpresse im Umland von Hannover. Das ist also ein Monopol im Grunde und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, Springer gab es auch noch. Springer gibt es auch noch, aber es gibt im Grunde diesen Monopolverlag und es gibt Springer, die dann natürlich auch eine Bildzeitung für Niedersachsen haben.
Genau.
Und die haben über die Jahre alle möglichen Dinge über die aktuelle Gattin des Bundespräsidenten geschrieben, was jetzt allerdings alles in irgendwelchen Archiven verschwunden ist.
Genau. Kennst du diesen von Gerd Prokop, der Stielschuh in Unterschenkel und der Sabenbankraub?
Nee.
Das ist so best of DDR-Sense-Fiction. Da gibt es so eine Geschichte, also der Held ist ein Detektiv, Entschuldigung fürs Abschreifen, aber die Geschichte ist zu passend. Der Held ist halt ein Detektiv in der Zukunft, das heißt ich, und was da passiert ist, dass eine Firma, die Leute einfriert, halt so eine Kryokonservation Firma, taut aus PR Gründen einen ihrer Eingefrorenen auf.
Um zu zeigen, dass es geht.
Um zu sagen, dass es geht. Und ist halt ein Fake. Und sie sind aber echt perfekt, also sie hat trainieren ihren Kandidaten, den sie da als aufgetorten präsentieren, halt nach allen Regeln der Kunst, mit irgendwie, kennt sich perfekt aus, spielt perfekt so. Und der Held, also der Detektiv, Timothy Truckel, bekommt den Auftrag, nachzuweisen, dass der ein Fake ist. Und findet dann, mit Hilfe seines Computers, der den schönen Namen Napoleon trägt, findet er dann, den ein Weg ist, tatsächlich nachzuweisen. Und zwar Geheimnisse, die jeder weiß, zu einer bestimmten Zeit, aber niemand gedruckt hat.
Und das ist eigentlich eine schöne Idee, so für mal drüber nachdenken beim zu Bett gehen. Was für Geschichten kennen wir, die eigentlich jeder irgendwie wusste, aber keiner hat drüber geschrieben.
Die nicht gedruckt werden. Genau so einen Effekt haben wir da auch gerade wieder. BP.
Ich hab gestern eine beeindruckende Verschwörungstheorie gehört, die muss ich hier mal kurz zum Besten geben. Also es geht nur mittelbar um BP. Also eine der Sachen, die bei BP ja erzählt wurde, ist, dass die Russen vorgeschlagen haben, mit einer Atombombe das Loch zu versiegen. Und der Gedankengang dahinter ist quasi, dass man daneben noch so einen Schacht bohrt. Und da macht man die Bombe rein und zündet die und dann schiebt die das Erdwerk zur Seite und macht den anderen Schacht zu. Also es klingt erstmal nicht völlig abwegig. Und das ist am Anfang total belächelt worden, als wir davon gehört haben. Und inzwischen wird da wohl ernsthaft über nachgedacht. Und also die Verschwörungstheorie hat mit BP nichts zu tun, aber mit Atombomben, deswegen komm ich da jetzt drauf.
Meine Atombombe ist immer gut.
Die Verschwörungstheorie kommt von Matthias Bröckers.
Das war schon mal eine Qualitätsverschwörungstheorie.
Also die Verschwörungstheorie heißt, dass sie, als sie das World Trade Center gebaut haben und den CS Tower, dass sie sich überlegt haben, hey, die sind so hoch, wenn wir die mal einreißen wollen, da haben wir gar keine Technologie für. Und dass sie deswegen eine Ausschreibung gemacht haben, um Sprengstoff im Fundament zu vergraben, und zwar Mininukes.
Mininukes?
Ja, das klingt so völlig absurd. Aber angeblich, wie das so ist bei Verschwörungstheorien, das hab ich noch nicht geprüft, aber angeblich sind diese Ausschreibungen tatsächlich on record. Und deswegen hätten die sich wohl so Sorgen gemacht, als es dann nachdem der WTC runterkam, und es hieß, oh, da ist ein Flugzeug auf dem Seastower im Anflug. Das war irgendwie, soll ja angeblich der Grund gewesen sein. Also nichts Genaues wissen wir nicht, aber es klingt einfach zu schön, um es für uns zu behalten.
Na interessant, also ich meine, so Sprengkammern so bei Brücken und so kennt man ja schon, also wenn der...
Das gibt es ja auch in Deutschland, wie ist das nun mal?
Die Operationen, weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Nee, irgendwas Meister, was war denn das? Brückenmeister?
Nee.
Also wir...
Weilmeister hieß die, glaub ich.
Weilmeister.
Genau, Weilmeister hieß die.
Also man kennt das ja aus der Schweiz, wer schon mal in der Schweiz im Urlaub war, die haben ihre Zufahrtsstraßen und strategischen Bergstraßen haben die tatsächlich, also nicht vermint, aber da haben die so versenkbare Stahlpfosten drin, die sie im Kriegsfall hochfahren können und die so stabil genug sind, dass die einen Panzer aufhalten sollen. Und so was Ähnliches gibt es bei uns eben auch. Und zwar sind Brücken mit Sprengkanälen versehen, wenn es also im Zweifelsfall davon ausgegangen wurde, dass der Feind über diese Rosse kommt. Genau, dass der Rosse kommt. Und dann haben sie die Brücken quasi mit Sprengstoff gefüllt. Und das kann dann im Notfall gezündet werden. Und da gibt es also tatsächlich die Berufsbezeichnung für einen Meister, die sich darum kümmert, diese Sprengkammern zu wagen. Was ja eigentlich ein richtig cooler Job ist so. Also man hat hier den beruflich, äh, äh...
Also was man dazu wissen muss, ist, dass die Sprengstoffe dafür wurden halt meistens in der Nähe gelagert. In so Erdbunkern, die minimal gesichert waren. Zu raff Hochzeiten machten die sich dann doch so ein bisschen Sorgen darum, äh, nachdem da irgendwie so Vorfälle gab. Aber die Details, was ich eigentlich mir so ganz im Kopf unterhalte...
Das ist eigentlich ein Problem, was immer wieder kommt. Also sowas hat man auch gehört von diesen Gladio, äh... Stay-Behind-Netzwerken. Da hieß es auch, ähm... Also aus Italien hieß es, da ist irgendwann eins dieser Lager...
hochgegangen, ja...
.hochgegangen. Und äh, das war offiziell, gab's das nicht.
Genau.
Und dann hieß es so, ja, wie kommt denn der ganze Sprengstoff dahin? Und dann waren wohl einige Leute......und, ja...
Ja, wir lagern den manchmal halt im Wald.
Ich mein, wenn man mal so ganz realistisch auf die Bedrohungslage guckt, dann haben wir also mehr Sprengstoff und Waffen vergraben von unseren eigenen Leuten als von den Terroristen.
Na, mittlerweile haben sie diese... diese Brücken-Sprengladung eingesammelt. Da gab's irgendwie nach der Wende dann ein großes Programm und da haben sie ein paar auch nicht gefunden gehabt zuerst, weil die Bunker schon überwuchert waren und so. Aber interessant ist ja, dass die, es gab ja dann eben vorwärts bei Hannover waren, in der Autobahn nach Hannover gab es auch solche Sprengrollen, die also zum Sprengen der Autobahn auf Westseite gedacht waren. Und die waren für britische Atomminen vorbereitet. Das heißt, die haben tatsächlich in der Richtung zwischen Magdeburg und Hannover, also in dem, in diesem Fulda-Gap, wie man es schon heißt, haben sie dann genau Atomminen vorgesehen gehabt, die sich dann halt in die Autobahn gesetzt hätten, um dann eine Haltung wie entsprechende Krater zu erzeugen und das Vordrängen des Russen zu verhindern.
Da gibt es ja sowieso die lustigsten Geschichten über bizarre Atomwaffen. Also die haben ja, unter anderem haben die so eine Art, so einen Raketenwerfer, den man auf die Schulter nimmt, genommen und da eine Mininuke reingebaut und da ist also im Grunde ausgeschlossen, dass der, der das Ding abfeuert, nicht selber verstrahlt wird. Aber also wenn man die Leute einfach nur machen lässt, dann kommen die mit den groteskesten Ideen.
Tja, mal sehen, ob BP nochmal auf den russischen Vorschlag zurückkommt.
Ich denke schon, das bleibt ihnen übrig.
Also angeblich haben sie ja heute ihren Rüssel da wohl ins Verliebe gekriegt.
Angeblich haben sie es zugemacht, ja, aber ich meine, das Problem ist ja, dass das Ding dann Druck bildet darunter, wenn es von unten gegen drückt. Und wenn du erstmal das einfach drauf machst, dann dauert es ein bisschen, bis der Druck groß genug ist, um da...
Es gab ja schon diese Gerüchte, dass der Seeboden schon gerissen ist und da irgendwie noch am Hau vorbei eine Menge sprudelt.
Es gibt da vielfältige Geschichten und es sieht alles nicht gut aus.
Interessant war ja auch diese Detail, dass sich dann herausstellt, dass es da ganz viele Bohrlöcher gibt, die alle so ein bisschen suppen und...
Ja, also insgesamt, wie viel waren es? 37.000 oder so, also eine unglaubliche Anzahl von Bohrungen hat es da gegeben und da gibt es eigentlich eine Behörde, die dafür zuständig ist, das zu verwalten.
Das waren noch die mit den Koks- und Sexparties mit irgendwie...
Ja, da gab es ja so vielfältige Verstrickungen. Aber jedenfalls, es gibt also einen Status namens temporär geschlossen. Und wenn man so ein Loch gerade hinterlässt und dann macht man einfach ein bisschen Kaugummi rein, dann ist es temporär geschlossen und man soll also innerhalb von einem Jahr planen, dann vorlegen, wie man das richtig zumacht.
Oder weiter benutzt.
Nö, also das macht sie eigentlich erst, nachdem du fertig bist mit dem Loch. Also so im Allgemeinen jedenfalls. Das heißt, im Grunde ist also die Idee, dass du das erst mal zumachst, dann kannst du dein Gerüst abfahren und deine Bohrinsel mitnehmen und dann machst du es richtig zu. Und nun sind irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wie viel es waren, aber es war vierstellig. Also vierstellig viele Löcher sind in diesem temporären Stadium seit über zehn Jahren. Und also das sind alles Zustände, das ist unglaublich. Das geht jetzt noch mal alles in die Busch-Ära zurück.
Na ja, in der Nordsee bohren sie auch. Und vor was war es? Vor Grünland?
Genau, vor Grünland. Also es gibt auch, Greenpeace hat das ja genutzt, um mal in der Nordsee zu gucken. Und wenn schon alle über Ölflecken auf dem Meer nachdenken, dann haben die mal so einen Helikopter gebietet und da so ein Meeresbiologen reingetan. Dann sind einfach mal die Bohrinseln abgeflogen und haben da auch überall Öltäppchen gesehen. Also jetzt keine Monster-Dinger wie im Golf von Mexiko. Aber das ist immer einfach mit dem Finger im Golf von Mexiko zu zeigen. Ja, bei uns sieht das nicht besser aus. BP bohrt ja auch gerade in Alaska. Auch so eine Tiefsee-Bohrung. Nur das Feld, was sie da im Golf von Mexiko angebohrt haben, gilt als kleines Feld. Und das, was sie in Alaska anbohren, gilt als großes Feld. Das heißt, wenn das aufgeht, dann können wir uns auch nochmal verabschieden.
Also spannend fand ich ja den ökonomischen Hintergrund, warum die solche Hochrisiko-Bohrungen machen. Der Hintergrund ist nämlich, dass die wirklich attraktiven Ölfelder, die halt mit relativ einfach Technologie auszubeuten werden und doch relativ attraktiv sind und gutes Öl enthalten, sind fast durchgehend mittlerweile in der Hand von nationalstaatlichen Ölgesellschaften. Das heißt also, die... Die so nahe alles so, Saudi-Arabien, Nigeria, Lateinamerika, also die großen Felder, Russland, sind halt alle mittlerweile tatsächlich wieder in der Hand der nationalen Ölgesellschaften. Und was denen den Supermultis bleibt, also BP und Shell und so weiter, ist halt entweder sich an diesen Feldern so ein bisschen zu beteiligen, aber da kann sie halt nicht genug Profit rausziehen, weil die Staaten die Kohle halt einsammeln.
Ach na, also die machen da schon genug Gewinn.
Klar, aber das ist halt jetzt nicht von den Fördervoluminen ist das halt relativ wenig. Und deswegen?
Na, sie sind halt abhängig davon, dass die Länder irgendwann sagen können, so, das hat ja der Iran irgendwann gemacht. Das war ja auch so eine Geschichte. Also, der Iran war ja ursprünglich britisches Protektorat und BP hat ja im Iran die Ölfelder sich gekrallt. Und das war eine der Sachen, die der Vorgänger des Schahs ändern wollte. Der wollte das alles nationalisieren. Der Iran hat den Briten angesagt, macht euch schon mal bereit, wir wollen das Öl dann selber haben. Und die Briten haben erst gedacht, das ist ein Witz. Das können die nicht ernst meinen.
Das macht man doch nicht.
Ja, das macht man doch nicht. Und deswegen gibt es sozusagen gerade die Theorie, dass BP auch hinter der Installation des Schahs in Iran steckt.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Die frühen Betreuungsgeschichten sind ja alle nicht weniger lecker als die heute.
Ja, im Gegenteil, da gibt es die Tollsichten. Es gab zum Beispiel aus dem Irak diese Geschichte, dass es hieß, die haben absichtlich nicht gefördert im Irak, weil sie nachgemessen haben, wie viel Öl das da gibt. Und dann haben sie gesagt, wenn wir das auf den Markt packen, dann sinkt einfach das Verhältnis von Angebot und Nachfrage. Und dann gehen uns die Preise kaputt. Und deswegen waren die ersten Jahre, als die Briten sich den Irak als Protektorat genommen haben, haben die absichtlich gesagt, hier wird jetzt nicht gefördert. So wissen sie ein bisschen für den Eigenbedarf. Aber deswegen sah es der Irak auf so großen Ölen vorkommen, weil die einfach nicht gefördert haben. Also da ist noch einiges aufzuarbeiten. Und da gibt es sicher auch, da kann doch das eine oder andere schön im Buch rausfallen.
Weil genau dieser Punkt, dass die großen Felder, die attraktiven Felder in der Hand der nationalen Ölgesellschaften sind, die die Super-Multis maximal als Dienstleistung dranlassen, aber eben nicht an den großen Gewinn, ist schon so statistisch gesehen. Und wozu das führt, ist eben, dass die Super-Multis dann halt anfangen, diese Hochrisikofelder zu machen. Man muss sich das mal vorstellen. Also wir haben Öl, das kommt noch in Saudi-Arabien aus der Wüste, wenn man da im Wesentlichen reinbohrt. Und dann ist es da.
Da kommt das von alleine raus.
Genau, da kommt das von alleine raus. Genau. Und da haben die aber nicht viel Aktie dran. Das hat halt Saudi-Aramco in der Hand.
Naja, Moment. Also es gab so Statistiken zum Golfkrieg. Also nach dem Golfkrieg ist ja erstmal der Ölpreis hochgegangen. Und da gab es dann Statistiken, dass Saudi-Arabien im Grunde pleite gegangen wäre, wenn das nicht so gewesen wäre. Weil die zwar, also die, es gab so eine, so eine, das war nicht eine Statistik, aber es war eine Auflistung, was ein Berylöl kostet auf dem Weg aus dem Boden zu uns in den Tank. Und das geht da für zwei Dollar raus und hier kostet es 150 Dollar. Und davon sehen die Saudi-Arabier nichts. Also die Saudi-Arabier, der Profit, von dem die leben, sind die zwei Dollar. Und natürlich gehört denen jetzt auch die Ölgesellschaft, die das fördert. Aber wenn es jetzt nicht Aramco fördern würde, sondern dann Geshell, also das ist nicht so, dass die Länder reich werden. Die einzigen, die reich werden, sind so Länder wie Venezuela und so. Also die Saudis haben sich tierisch über den Tisch ziehen lassen. Und eines der Mittel, um die Saudis über den Tisch zu ziehen, war ja auch, dass das alles in Dollar abgewickelt wird.
Klar. Aber der Fakt bleibt halt, dass die Supermultis auf die großen Felder immer weniger Zugriff haben, was dann halt dazu führt, dass sie eben genau solche Hochgiesekundnummern machen. Also man muss sich das ja mal plastisch vorstellen. Also ich hab halt mal beim Fahrradfahren festgestellt, dass ich morgens zur Arbeit genauso lange Fahrrad fahre, wie die oben von ihrem Schiff bis zum Öl haben. Nämlich fast sieben Kilometer. Die haben da halt einfach so tausende Meter Wasser und dann bohren sie noch mal 1500 Meter da rein in den Boden. Bohren dabei auch noch um die Ecke, damit sie einen möglichst großen Flow in dieses Ölfeld haben. Das ist echt unglaublich.
Übrigens, um die Ecke bohren macht man nicht nur unterm Seeboden, sondern es hat auch Kuwait gemacht, um sich an dem Öl vom Irak zu beteiligen. Vom Irak so wütig zu tun, bevor Saddam da einmarschiert ist. Also es gab da schon auch einen Grund für die Invasion, oder ist das nicht?
Naja, zumindest. Also die streiten sich ja immer noch darüber, vor der UNO, glaube ich, mittlerweile.
Naja, aber ich meine, das ist wohl unbestritten, dass Kuwait sich da an Vorhaben beteiligt hat, die eigentlich zum überwiegenden Teil nicht unter ihrem Land liegen.
Ja, naja, das ist halt der Wüste nicht wahr. Und dann haben wir versehentlich um die Ecke gebohrt. Oder so ähnlich. Keine Ahnung.
Das Zwiftabkommen ist jetzt endgültig übern Jordan.
Genau. Und hier alle Parteien sind umgefallen.
Ja, also der ein oder andere ist sich vielleicht nicht im Klaren, warum unsere Politiker den zustimmen würden. Und das sollten wir vielleicht auch nochmal kurz erklären. Also der Hintergrund ist nämlich der, dass unsere Dienste da keinen Zugriff drauf haben auf die Daten. Aber die Amerikaner haben dank des Abkommens Zugriff darauf und wir haben ein Abkommen mit den Amerikanern, dass diese Daten getauscht werden. Das heißt, das ist quasi die Hintertür, damit unsere Dienste an die Daten reinkommen und dass die Amis, die dann aussehen, da können wir dann mitleben.
Das ist ja ohnehin das Prinzip auch gerade bei Abhöroperationen.
Deswegen haben wir auch diese Satelliten ins All geschossen, gerade damit wir was zum Handeln haben.
Zum Trauben. Zum Trauben. Na, da gibt es ja dann, also bei diesen Satellitenprogrammen scheint da mittlerweile auf dem Trip zu sein, Sachen zu machen, die die Amerikaner gerade nicht machen können oder wollen.
Na, die Amis sind halt gerade am Runterfahren von ihrem Space-Programm. Aus Kostengründen. Und da, das ist, hat gerade eine Renaissance ausgelöst in den Weltraum-Industrien der Welt im Grunde. Die sind alle, sie nennen es alle Morgenluft.
Vor allen Dingen sind sie ja auch sehr viel billiger, ne? Also ich meine, wenn du dir anguckst, für wie wenig, relativ...
Und das ist ja egal, wenn du das Geld selber drücken kannst.
Klar, aber ich meine, wenn du dir so anguckst, für wie relativ wenig, also wenig Geld ist natürlich übertrieben, aber etwa nur ein paar hundert Millionen, die dieses Saarloupe-System gebaut haben, also diesen Radar aus dem Weltraum, mit dem man halt so 1-Meter-Objekte oder vielleicht sogar besser auflöten kann.
Vor allem kann man damit durch die Wolken gucken. Also das ist wohl der Hauptvorteil gegenüber dem bisherigen autischen System. Das ist schon technisch eine coole Sache, nur man fragt sich natürlich, was konkret macht man damit denn so?
Wahrscheinlich Abfragprämienautos zählen.
Genau, Maut-Inforcement. Ich muss nämlich wissen, Maut, da sind wir Exportmeister.
Genau, für Maut-Inforcement bietet sich das natürlich auch an, das ist vollkommen klar.
Wieso ist Swift eigentlich nach Europa gezogen? War doch total bescheuert, die morgens direkt in Amerika bleiben können.
Waren die schon immer in Europa?
Nee, das war doch der Lacher, dass die Server in Amerika waren. Und da gab es so einen Aufschrei.
Die haben die Server in Amerika gehabt, aber nur weil da so viele Transaktionen stattfanden.
Ja, aber ich meine, irgendwann haben sie gesagt, aus Datenschutzgründen ziehen wir jetzt die Server nach Europa. Und der ganze, das ganze Bruhaha, was wir jetzt hier haben, von wegen SWIFT-Abkommen, das wäre alles überhaupt nicht nötig gewesen, wenn wir den einfach in Amerika gelassen hätten.
Na ja, aber SWIFT selber ist ja eine europäische Firma. Also die waren ja nur in Amerika, weil es so viele...
Das ist nicht so eine Kommune irgendwie, sondern es ist schon eine Firma, aber nicht...
Die sind von europäischen Ursprüngen.
Ja, ja. Das ist ja auch eine französische Abkürzung irgendwie.
Die haben ja diesen Bunker da in Belgien, wo sie halt irgendwie ihre vorbegräbigen Zentren haben und so.
Die machen halt Transaktionen zwischen Ländern.
Also internationale Banküberweisungen, was eigentlich stimmt. Ja, dann hat man das.
Polizeibrutalität. Die lacht mich an.
Die Polizeibrutalität?
Da haben wir uns gerade sehr gefreut, weil nämlich Amnesty International eine Kampagne losgetreten hat.
Die ist natürlich so ein bisschen zweischneidig, ne?
Die fordern mehr Überwachung. Das ist natürlich eine Sache.
Interessant ist ja, dass sie de facto dort wappnen, in so diversen Zeifis, schon eine Weile da ist. Nämlich Evidence-Cams. Zuletzt halt irgendwie bei Charles Strauss in seinem Roman. Da ist es halt so, dass jeder Polizisten mehrere Kameras an sich und um sich trägt. Und diese Kameras zeichnen halt alles auf. Und das Endes, die jetzt fordert, ist, dass zumindest ein Polizeigewahrsam alles wahrscheinlich auf Video aufgezeichnet wird. Um halt so hochtest die Treppe runtergefallen zu verhindern.
Naja, das Problem bei sowas ist eben, wir haben das ja schon mehrfach gehabt in Deutschland, dass dann eigentlich die Beweise da waren, aber dann aus der Asservatenkammer verschwunden sind. Insofern, solange die Cam von der Polizei betrieben wird, ist das kein echter Vorteil in meinen Augen. Also das wird einfach genauso verschwinden wie... Die haben doch diese schöne Studie gemacht zu der Freiheit statt Angstdemon. Da haben wir mal die ganzen Zugriff auf die Polizeiaufnahmen gekriegt und haben gesehen, dass die weggeguckt haben. Also die haben aktiv weggeguckt, wenn es aussah, als würde es da gleich Gewalt geben. Dann haben die extra weggeguckt.
Also von Polizisten gegen Demonstranten. Genau.
Und das wird mit Evidence-Camps nicht anders sein.
Ja, ich finde es zumindest interessant, dass das Amnesty jetzt zumindest mal versucht, genau dieses Feld mit Technologie zu machen.
Sie fordern auch Auszeichnungen der Beamten. Das fordern wir auch schon länger.
Genau. Also die Kennzeichnungspflicht ist natürlich sicherlich eine Sache, für die es eigentlich keinen guten Grund dagegen mehr gibt. Da kann man technische Lösungen finden für die Bedenken, die es bezüglich persönlicher Angrifbarkeit gibt. Also es gibt eigentlich keinen Grund, warum in einem zivilisierten Land die Polizisten nicht kennzeichnet sein sollten. Also ich muss jetzt mal vergingert denken. Die Polizei hat in diesem Land das Gewaltmonopol. Und wenn wir uns so die diversen Meldungen angucken, die wir so über die letzten Jahre hatten, auch dieses Jahr hatten, dann ist die Frage schon berechtigt, was für Leute werden dieses Gewaltmonopol eigentlich in die Hand geben. Also besonders krass fand ich diese Geschichte, die ich spiegelanlern jetzt gerade hatte, wo sich dann irgendwie herausstellte, dass offensichtlich Polizisten in der Näheren Bekannt- und Verwandtschaft zu haben tatsächlich ein Risiko ist. Da war es halt so, da war eine Frau ermordet worden und sie haben ihren Ex-Mann, Beschuldigten, festgelegt offensichtlich.
Weil einer der mittelnden Beamten war?
Genau, der mittelnde Beamte war der neue Freund von der Frau. Und zumindest so wie sich der Bericht las, wäre es wohl sinnvoll gewesen, den auch als Verdächtigen zu betrachten.
Was sie wohl inzwischen auch tun, also das hat sich...
8 Jahren oder so was?
Ja, also solange sah es der Angehalt.
Genau, also insofern, wie gesagt, also diese Frage nach der Verantwortbarkeit von Gewaltmonopol und der Rechenschaftspflicht von Gewaltmonopol, die muss man halt einfach deutlich stellen. Also die Konzeption halt zu sagen, es gibt halt irgendwie nur Einträge von Gewaltmonopol in diesem Staat, nämlich die Polizei bedeutet andersherum halt auch, dass man da ganz klar verlangen muss, dass da Rechenschaft geleistet wird und dass die sich nicht halt hinter so einem Korpsgeist verstecken können.
Na, es gibt noch eine andere Alternative. Also es gab ja gerade dieses Urteil bezüglich der, also bei der Freiheit und Angst-Demo gab es ja diesen Polizeigewalt-Fall, den wir auch thematisiert haben und der am Ende dazu geführt hat, dass wir jetzt in Berlin die Beamten beschriften. Und da haben sie natürlich, naja, also es ist jedenfalls ein paar Mal angesagt worden.
Na, die Gewerkschaft der Polizei strott sich da immer noch.
Strott sich immer noch, ja, aber es sieht aus als können sie nicht.
Ich glaube ich erst, wenn ich es auf der Straße sehe.
Also jedenfalls, was sie dann gemacht haben, ist natürlich ein Verfahren und Ermittlungen, aber nicht etwa gegen die Polizisten, sondern gegen den Demonstranten, der verprügelt wurde, weil nämlich die Polizisten selbstverständlich ausgesagt haben, der habe sich widersetzt und habe mit Steinen geworfen und sei vermummt gewesen und alles Mögliche. Und der Richter, nachdem jetzt die Verteidigung von dem Demonstranten die Tapes mal zusammengeschnitten hat, sodass man quasi aus allen möglichen Winkeln die Timeline gut sehen kann, da sieht man halt, der hat sich überhaupt nicht widersetzt und hat auch nicht mit Steinen geworfen und war auch nicht vermummt und gar nichts. Da meinte der Richter dann, naja, der hätte sich ja wehren können.
Ja, das fand ich schon verprüfend, ja.
Also ich meine, rein rechtlich gesehen ist das natürlich so, dass man sich zur Wehr setzen darf, wenn die Gewaltanleihung nicht rechtmäßig ist. Aber wenn man sich das mal überlegt, was der Richter da sagt, dann ist diese Passivbewaffnung noch eine viel größere Schweinerei, als sie eh schon ist.
Du meinst das Verbot der Passivbewaffnung?
Wenn das das Korrektiv ist, was wir laut dem Richter haben, dass wir uns dann ja wehren können, dann ist es umso krasser, dass sie das gegen mich auslegen, wenn ich auf einer Demo mit einem dicken Pulli komme. Oder mit einem Schutzhelm oder so. Da ist ja immer die Argumentation, das sei Passivbewaffnung. Genau, Passivbewaffnung ist ja. Weil damit kann ich zwar keinem wehtun, aber damit würde ich verhindern, dass die Polizei mir wehtut. Also das heißt, sie nehmen mir erst die Mittel weg, um mich im Zweifelsfall wehren zu können. Und sagen mir danach, ich hätte mich doch wehren können. Das finde ich schon sehr apart.
Wie gesagt, der einzige Weg da raus ist eben das Korrektiv dahingehend, dass sich die Polizei der Transparenzpflicht stellen muss. Und sich da nicht hinter diesen immer wieder betonten, aber dann greifen uns doch die bösen Jungs alle privat an, verstecken kann. Da gibt es Mittel und Wege, das zu lösen. Das ist jetzt einfach in einem zivilisierten Land nicht mehr würdig, das nicht zu tun. Also es gibt andere Bundesländer, wo die kein Zeichen sind, da gibt es keine Probleme.
Also lustigerweise gibt es ja bei Beleidigungen im Strafgesetzbuch die Regelung, dass wenn beide Seiten sich gegenseitig beleidigen, dann ist keine davon strafbar. Also das ist sozusagen, was eine sehr schlaue Regelung ist. Ja, denn wenn quasi jemand kommt und mich anpöbelt öffentlich und mich pöbelt zurück, dann ist nichts passiert. Ja, aber wenn man das mal weiter anwendet auf Brutalität bei Demonstrationen, das würde den 1. Mai noch mal so richtig in Schwung bringen.
Also das hat dann schon eher so die von diesen Hooligans, die sich unter grünen Wiese treffen, um sich gepflegt zu verprügeln.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn du die anguckst, also ich weiß ja nicht nach welchen Kriterien die Berliner Polizei ihre Mitarbeiter auswählt.
Aber ich glaube, großkräftig korsgeschon.
Die berühmten beiden Kolonnen, die auch bei der Freistaat Angstdemo am Start waren, die sehen alle schon aus, als wenn die, also wenn sie Urlaub haben, schon auch an irgendwelchen Straßenschlachten mitmachen könnten, so von der Statue her. Insofern, soweit sehen sie nicht voneinander entfernt. Na ja, das kommt ja auch immer wieder vor, das ist ja immer ein persönliches Highlight.
Da gab es diese Geschichte doch in Kanada gerade, bei dem G20.
Genau, also es gibt vor allem auch immer wieder Fälle, wo die Polizei dann und Undercover-Kollegen verprügelt. Na ja, manchmal ist es ja Absicht sozusagen. Also jetzt in Kanada sind ja Provokateure, aber es gibt eben auch Fälle, wo Undercover-Leute eingeschleust werden, um zu beobachten und dann im Nachhinein die Leute identifizieren zu können, was sie halt die vorher schon gesehen haben. Und wenn die dann krankenhausreif geprügelt werden, weil sie einfach zu gut getan standen, das lässt schon tief blicken, dass da so viel Auswahl, der Prügel ziel, auch wenn man nicht stattfindet.
Aber auch Homöopathie können wir noch machen?
Homöopathie können wir machen. Das ist gerade so eine Sache, das kocht gerade so ein bisschen hoch. Weil, also eigentlich ist es ja eine Nebelkerze, wenn man nämlich mal guckt, wie viel Geld tatsächlich für Homöopathie ausgegeben wird, das ist irgendwie ein Prozent des Budgets.
Das ist weniger sogar.
Der Krankenkassen, also das spielt im Grunde keine Rolle.
Und der interessante Punkt ist ja, dass die Krankenkassen ja sagen, dass ihnen total egal ist, ob es nun wirtschaftlich belegt ist, dass es wirksam ist oder nicht.
In Krankenkassen ist es wurscht, weil es nämlich billiger ist, als wenn ein Krauter eine Operation an dir durchführt.
Oder sie halt zum richtigen Psychotherapeuten gehen.
Es gibt ja so Witze, wenn einer sich krank fühlt, dass die Diagnose immer vom Arzt abhängt. Also wenn du dann zum Psychiater gehst, dann ist das psychosomatisch gewesen. Wenn du zum Orthopäden gehst, hast du ja was Gelenkprobleme. Internist findet irgendein Verdauungsproblem. Und so ist es halt. Der Orthopäde gibt dir, der Homöopath gibt dir halt verdünntes Wasser. Und das wirkt vielleicht nicht. Aber das Problem hat man ja mit der Normalmedizin auch. Und das ist immerhin billig. Das ist die Ansage der Krankenkassen.
Naja, ich glaube, das ist sogar noch ein bisschen komplexer, weil wenn man es jetzt so angucken, ist es ja so, dass es durchaus einen großen Teil von Krankheiten gibt, die nun relativ unspezifisch sind. Und wo halt vermutlich die Ursachen doch eher psychosomatischer Natur sind.
Vor allem ist es so, dass die Selbstheilungsquote einfach bei 75 Prozent liegt. Das heißt, bei so Ding wie Wehchen, die die Leute haben. Und wenn du da einfach alle Leute erstmal mit einem Placebo nach Hause schickst, da könnte man wahrscheinlich enorme Summen sparen.
Also die interessante Frage ist halt eben genau, warum ist es so, dass auswisslich die Homöopathie der einzig sinnvolle Weg ist, Placebos wirksam zu verabreichen?
Ist es ja nicht, also ist es nicht. Das ist durchaus üblich in Krankenhäusern, die haben halt ihre eigene Apotheke und die machen dann eben... Ja, natürlich, die bereiten sich ihre eigenen Sachen zu und das ist eine eigene Kunst, so ein Placebo so zu machen, dass es ernsthaft aussieht. Das muss also einen guten Namen haben. Zum Beispiel bewährt ist, wenn es irgendwas Forte heißt. Also wenn du zum Beispiel eine physikalische Kochzeitlösung hast, dann gibt es physikal Forte. Und das muss dann gespritzt werden. Also eine Pille reicht nicht. Ein Placebo wirkt erst gut, wenn es gespritzt wird, und zwar vom Chefarzt. Also der Oberarzt, das wirkt weniger gut. Und es gibt ja Untersuchungen zu Placebos, die wirken besser, wenn sie teuer sind. Also deswegen, der Chefarzt spritzt das. Das kostet mehr, als wenn der Oberarzt spritzt.
Und der Chefarzt sagt nochmal, dass ich der Chefarzt tue, Medikament aus Amerika.
Das ist aber hier das besonders scharfe Zeug. Das machen wir nur ausnahmsweise. Und es gibt tatsächlich Probleme. Teilweise, dass die Patienten dann wiederkommen und das Medikament haben wollen, was so gut geholfen hat. Das kann es ihnen natürlich nicht geben, weil wenn sie es in die Hand kriegen, da steht ja drauf, dass da für Wirkstoffe drin sind. Und das sind halt keine.
Verstehe, das heißt, da muss man die noch in eine spezifische Art der Anwendung verpacken, die man im Krankenhaus mitkriegt.
Also das eigentliche Problem, was wir haben, ist, dass wir viel zu schnell Diagnostik betreiben, weil einfach die Ärzte irgendwelche Geräte angeschafft haben und die amortisieren müssen. Die müssen sich amortisieren und dazu müssen die angewendet werden. Und deswegen der letzte, zu dem man gehen sollte, bei sowas ist bei der Radiologe, weil der hat die teuersten Geräte. Also eigentlich, da sollte man erst hingehen, wenn alles andere gescheitert ist. Es gab ja gerade bei der Roten Kreuz Krankenhäuser in Berlin, haben wir gerade so ein Abrednungsgradual gehabt. Genau, da war auch Radiologe beteiligt. Das ist eigentlich immer so, weil die haben derart Unsummen, müssen die ausgeben für ihre Geräte, dass man das also auf rechtlich einwandfreien Weg gar nicht refinanziert kriegt. Und deswegen haben die sich so eine Fließband-Methodik entwickelt.
Für die Abrechnungsoptimierung?
Nee, das ist natürlich der eine Weg, bei den Abrechnungen zu bescheißen. Aber der andere Weg ist einfach, dass der Radiologe tatsächlich da so ein Fließband-Ding einrichtet und dann wirst du da geröntgt und es dauert so was wie drei Minuten. Und hinter dir ist schon der nächste in der Schlange und die Geräte werden gar nicht kühl zwischen den Benutzungen, weil anders amortisiert sich das halt nicht. Verstehe. Und das liegt vor allem daran, dass in unserem System die Preise nicht verhandelt werden müssen. Also wenn jemand ein Medikament herstellt und ein Arzt verschreibt das, dann gibt es genau einen, der das abnimmt, nämlich die Kasse und die ist gesetzlich verpflichtet, das zu zahlen. Die kann also nicht anfangen rum zu verhandeln mit dem Hersteller und sagen, damit zahle ich jetzt aber nur die Hälfte für. Und daher können die Hersteller im Grunde an Preisen aufrufen, was sie wollen, weil es da nämlich keine Regulierung gibt in Deutschland, im Gegensatz zum Ausland. In Österreich kostet das einfach mal die Hälfte, die ganzen Medikamente, weil da gibt es Regulierung. Lustigerweise richtet sich das Ausland nach Deutschland. Da gab es neulich so einen Artikel, ich glaube, in der Süddeutschen, die warten, bis die Deutschen das Medikament am Markt haben und dann nehmen sie den Preis, den man hier zahlt, mal irgendwie 0,5.
Verstehe.
Das heißt also, wir werden einfach abgezockt von den Pharma-Industrien und im Moment, also ich beteilige mich da auch gerne, gibt es natürlich ein großes Gebäsche gegen die Homöopathie, weil es einfach mal Verarschung ist.
Aber zumindest, also ich meine, die interessante Frage ist halt, ja wie könnte man sozusagen Mechanismus bauen, der dafür sorgt, dass genau die Leute zum Homöopathen gehen, die halt denen hilft. Also die halt irgendwie davon profitieren, dass sie sich eine Stunde, eineinhalb mit ihnen hinsetzt, sich darüber unterhält, was sie essen und so weiter.
Spannenderweise sind es ja nicht die Doven, die da mehr drauf reinfallen, sondern die Schlauen fallen mehr drauf rein.
Der Punkt ist, reinfallen ist ja relativ.
Wenn es ihnen am Ende geholfen hat, Nein, ich meine also im Sinne von, die sich Sachen ausschwatzen lassen, die nur einen Placeboeffekt haben. Das wirkt besser bei Leuten, die eine höhere Schulbildung haben. Weil wenn die einmal sich festgelegt drauf haben, dass ihnen es jetzt hilft, dann glauben die da viel stärker dran, weil sie die Erfahrung haben, einfach Recht zu haben mit ihren Überlegungen. Deswegen wirkt das besser bei Uni-Abgängern als bei Hauptschülern.
Es gibt ja Mechanismen, also wenn du eine Ausbildung hast, dann lernst du, wenn der blutet, dann schickst du ihn mal zum richtigen Arzt. Oder wenn es aussieht wie eine Infektion, die vielleicht ein Antibiotikum kriegt, dann gibt es vielleicht doch keine Globuli. Aber am Ende ist ja schon die Frage, die Menschheit hat ja über Tausende von Jahren irgendwie schamanistische Heilung betrieben. Und tatsächlich ist ja der Differential zwischen die Heilung der Schulmedizin, also sozusagen wie viel Prozent mehr Leute geheilt werden können durch Schulmedizin, lässt sich ja durchaus messen. Und alle anderen brauchen das ja nicht. Also für alle anderen Fälle. Irgendwann braucht es ja jeder.
Also es gibt ja mal diesen Kabarettauftritt von Volker Pispas, wo er meint, der Marburger Ring sei in Streit getreten. Das ist irgendwie die ernste Gemeinschaft.
Also eine der ärztlichen Gemeinschaften.
Ja, die seien irgendwie in Streit getreten und daraufhin sei die Mortalitätsrate in Deutschland deutlich gesunken. Also es ist nicht so, dass die Schulmedizin alle Antworten hat. Aber wenn man das, diese Schamanismusdebatte finde ich aus dem anderen Gesichtspunkt interessant, weil eins unserer größten Probleme im Moment ist ja die Überbevölkerung.
Nein, nicht hier in Deutschland.
Nein, nicht in Deutschland, aber so weltweit. Und das war erst ein Problem, als unsere Ärzte anfingen gut zu werden. Bevor wir wussten, dass es Bakterien gibt und die alle schamanistisch geheilt waren, hat sich das alles im natürlichen Gleichgewicht bewunden.
Naja, ich würde jetzt nur nicht glorifizieren wollen, dass die Leute Lebenserwartungen von 35 hatten.
Nein, nein, aber man muss sich da auch schon im Klaren darüber sein, was wir hier machen mit unserer Schulmedizin. Wir greifen da in die Natur ein. Das hat gute und schlechte Seiten. Man muss das eben dann kompensieren, indem man weniger Nachwuchs hat. Was im Übrigen von alleine passiert. Also, sobald die Immortalitätsrate sinkt, sinkt auch der Nachwuchs.
Da gibt es auch die Korrelation zur wirtschaftlichen Situation. Also, je reicher die Leute werden, desto weniger Nachwuchs brauchen sie. Also, am Ende ist das...
Das hängt auch damit ab, wie viele Kinder halt durchkommen. Wenn du Kinderzeugen musst, damit zwei erwachsen werden.
Mhm, klar. Aber die interessante Frage ist ja schon, genau, also wenn wir uns angucken, so Medizinkosten wachsen ja dramatisch. Also, das nimmt ja immer einen großen Anteil der Volkswirtschaft in Anspruch. Und die Frage ist ja, wenn, also wie bekommt man die halbwegs in den Griff? Und insofern, jetzt nur pauschal auf die Homöopathie einzudreschen, ist zwar lustig, weil irgendwie keine wissenschaftliche Grundlage, sondern halt irgendwie Wässerchen so. Aber die Frage ist halt, welchen, welchen Mechanismus entwickeln wir, um den Leuten halt eben so eine schamanistische Halbplacebo-Behandlung zu geben, denen es halt hilft, weil die ist halt konkurrenzlos billig.
Naja, im Zweifelsfall müsste man es allen geben, ne? Also, das wäre in meinen Erachtens die einzige Variante, die funktioniert, dass die die Schulindustrie müsste man also das das Hauptproblem ist ja, dass die Ärzte alle Angst haben müssen, dass sie ihre Miete nicht zahlen können. Die Ärzte haben nach oben hin, sind die gedeckelt, wie viele Einnahmen sie haben können. Aber ihre Ausgaben sind halt auch fix. Das heißt, sie müssen mindestens so und so viel erreichen und es ist halt ein Knochenjob. Und wenn die Ärzte jetzt nicht Sorgen haben müssen, dass sie ihre ihre Miete zahlen können, dann hätten sie auch Zeit für die Patienten. Das ist, glaube ich, eines der Probleme. Also die Placebos wirken ja nicht, wenn du sie am Fließband bei der Schulmedizin kriegst, sondern nur, wenn der Arzt sich Zeit nimmt, sich dann die VWchen anhört und dir eine schöne Geschichte erzählt, wie dieses Placebo jetzt konkret gemacht wird und warum es funktioniert. Und das ist schon seit vielen Jahren. Und Ayurveda und Indien, dann wirkt das.
Ja, nicht nur das. Ich meine, es ist ja häufig auch so, dass die Leute sich halt falsch ernähren oder irgendwelche verdeckten Allergien haben oder so ein Scheiß, wo du halt einfach nur durch Nachfragen drauf kommst. Und wenn du nicht nachfragst, dann kriegst du da nicht raus.
Ja, also es gibt ja so eine Geschichte aus dem Klinikalltag. Wenn man eine Spritze braucht beim Orthopäden, dann macht der die immer ins Gelenk. Und das liegt daran, dass der 50 Cent kriegt, wenn er die in Spritze setzt, aber er kriegt 5 Euro, wenn er die ins Gelenk setzt. Und deswegen kriegst du beim Orthopäden immer alle Spritzen ins Gelenk. Das gibt überhaupt keinen Grund dafür, medizinisch gesehen. Im Gegenteil, aber da kriegt halt der Arzt viel. Und solange es solche Mechanismen gibt, solange der Arzt sich da seine Abrechnung zusammen optimieren muss, so viel Gehirn hat er dann weniger übrig, um sich um den Patienten zu kümmern. Und deswegen denke ich, da könnte vieles sich von alleine lösen, wenn wir mal die Finanzierung überarbeiten. Homöopathie, das ist halt ein dankbares Ziel.
Am schönsten wäre noch die Geschichte mit dem...
Der Oldspiel, das sich auch durch Homöopathie löst.
Ja, das war gerade ein Huffington-Post oder so was.
Ja, das war ein Kommentar.
Genau, eine Kolumne, dass man doch den Ölteppich im Golf von Mexiko auch auflösen könnte, indem man ein wenig Öl einnimmt und eine Million verdünnt und es dann über den Golf von Mexiko aussprünkelt. Genau. Da.
Und dann geht das von alleine weg, ist das nicht toll?
Da freuen wir uns dann schon drauf. Ach, halt, wir haben noch eins vergessen, ja, Fletter.
Ja, genau. Also wir haben uns vorgenommen, das mal mit dem Fletter auszuprobieren.
Genau. Also deswegen gibt es auf Alternativlos auch einen Fletter-Button. Und wenn euch der Podcast gefallen hat und ihr wollt, dass wir mehr davon machen und wir uns auch ein bisschen bessere Ausrüstung kaufen können, um irgendwie die Aufnahmengualität zu verbessern, die wir momentan hier noch so mit improvisierten Bordmitteln gemacht haben, dann drückt doch mal auf diesen Fletter-Button. Und wenn die Einnahmen exzessiv steigen sollten, dann gehen wir davon mal Eis essen. Also dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank fürs Flettern. Bis zum nächsten Mal.